the ICU is really where you go when
you're very sick it's a really intense
interventionist environment and so when
you're in the ICU you really need to
know how acutely ill an individual is so
you can decide whether you need to
specify treatments very quickly or
whether you need to focus more care on
them there's a tremendous amount of
information that the doctors and nurses
and all the care staff are actually
encoding in some of these notes that
they take and a lot of that is just
harder to access you know it's not a
nice set of codes that are already you
know pre sorted in some very easy-to-use
way it's just sort of this free text
that's a sprawl and very difficult to
use but probably contains more
informative things about the underlying
patient state so there's a patient and
he's really really sick and then there's
a doctor and she's totally overwhelmed
because patients generates so much data
there's basically a zillion notes and
constant signals who can keep up with a
thousand Hertz oh yeah I guess there's
also that other stuff like age and
gender and QT scores seems pretty
important to think about and maybe that
would all be okay if there was just one
patient but there are so so many
patients and the modern ICU so here's
what this doctor really was she'd like a
real-time indicator of how sick each
patient is and let's see on a scale of
faking it to dead
and maybe beyond but how can she get
that that's where we come in we can
predict how safe patients are by looking
at their notes which is great because
there's a lot of notes nearly half a
million from nineteen thousand three
hundred and eight patients using a
couple of magical fancy looking plates
we can model common topics that we find
in the notes and then for each patient
we can figure out which topics are the
most relevant to them then you say hey I
feel like you're saying a lot of words
that are related to the topic of septic
shock you may not think your patient is
going through septic shock but maybe
they're going to at some point soon so
maybe you should you know take a look at
them right now or
try some more interventionist techniques
at this point if you look at our
population the baseline mortality is
about 11% well what we can see is the
relative mortality of the topics is
pretty different from that some are
really high like this one that looks
like it's about respiratory failure with
words like intubated and fanned
secretions definitely not a topic you
won in your notes but some are really
low like this one that looks like it's
about broken bones broken bones hurt but
they don't usually kill you and even
better we can look at how the topics
change in time for each new note that
comes in which is great because usually
the information that a doctor gets at
admission that baseline data is less and
less predictive over time since the
notes accumulate they don't start off
doing that well but they get more and
more predictive and when we use both of
them together and combine the models it
helps us get a prediction that's great
from the time the patient shows up to
the time that they leave the hospital
everything I hear about now related to
clinical care is all about can we make
more space for doctors to be doctors and
less room for them to be accountants and
note takers and you know transcript
ist's or whatever it is right we want to
allow doctors to actually feel like
they're making decisions about a
patient's care right and what I would
hope is if a system like this really was
implemented it would allow doctors to
spend more time caring for patients
you